the director of national intelligence
has declassified documents today
revealing
former c.i.a director john brennan
briefed then
president obama on hillary clinton's
purported plan
to smear then-candidate trump in 2016.
adding to what the national intelligence
director has already declassified
on this issue and raising more questions
tonight
about how much more of this will come
out before election day
senior political correspondent mike
emanuel is following the story tonight
in washington good evening mike
brett good evening these are handwritten
notes from former cia director john
brennan written according to a source
familiar
after brennan briefed president obama at
one point brennan writes
quote approved by hillary clinton a
proposal from one of her foreign policy
advisers
to vilify donald trump by stirring up a
scandal claiming interference by the
russian security service
the notes say on 28 of july in the
margin brennan writes potus but that
section of the notes are redacted
then it says any evidence of
collaboration between trump campaign and
russia
the remainder of the notes are redacted
except in the margins where it says
jc dennis and susan that could be
referring to former fbi director james
comey
former obama chief of staff dennis
mcdonough and former national security
adviser susan rice
the cia sent a memo to former fbi
director james comey and peter strzok
writing quote
the following information is provided
for the exclusive use of your bureau
for background investigative action or
lead
purposes as appropriate one example the
cia includes
quote an exchange redacted discussing
u.s presidential candidate hillary
clinton's approval of a plan
concerning u.s presidential candidate
donald trump and russian hackers
hampering u.s elections
as a means of distracting the public
from the her use of a private email
server
at a hearing before the senate judiciary
committee last week comey was pressed on
what he did with information provided by
the cia
did you open an investigation i don't
know what that refers to as i said
earlier that does not ring any bells
with me when i read that
you did not receive any investigative
referral of this nature
i don't remember it i don't i don't
remember receiving anything
that's described in that letter hillary
clinton spokesman nick merrill has
called the latest revelation
quote baseless bs